it was straight out of the pages of a
detective novel a man bombs a team bus
from one of Germany's biggest football
clubs hoping the club's publicly traded
stock would get hammered he had bought
put options which would have paid off
big if the shares plunged regardless of
whether players were injured or even
killed it was she agreed that was an
extreme example but greed is a natural
human trait it pushes us to strive and
secure resources but it can also be our
undoing
Reiner Foss is someone who's familiar
with greed he made a lot of money as an
investment banker when it comes to
financial greed there's a certain point
where it's no longer about money as such
money stops being something he used to
fulfill material needs and becomes a
measure of your value as a person that's
one of the defining problems of our time
there's a word for it financialization
we've come to view many or even all
things in our lives only in terms of
their monetary value bankers have the
reputation of being especially greedy
all the more so since their actions 10
years ago almost caused the entire
financial system to collapse investors
and savers are still feeling the effects
Reiner Foss personally experienced the
excesses of greed he quit when it became
too much for him it's a parallel world
and you don't care what happens outside
of it to realize that you're harming
other people you need a basic
understanding of cause and effect I'd
say most of the people who set off the
crisis back then don't have that you
have to realize these are people who no
longer take the subway or go to the
supermarket they don't even go to the
hairdresser the hairdresser comes to
them it's a parallel world a bubble
more wealth more luxury more power do we
actually ever get enough accumulating
money and material goods is the source
of prestige the more we possess the more
our value increases in the eyes of
others our fear of loss of self-worth is
also what's behind our greed
in corporations greed can raise its head
in the form of graft money laundering or
market manipulation Peter grassman was
once CEO of the optical company
card-sized and a top executive at
engineering giant siemens now he writes
books calling for corporations to
respect ethical values of honesty and
decency in many cases your options are
limited for example when Mexico raised
the kickbacks from 3 to 5 percent we
said we're not going to play along
anymore
that cut seaman's market share in half
and the Japanese got the deal one
company doing the right thing isn't
enough for the world to change
that's why politicians and business
associations have to keep a closer watch
on the code of ethics but in the end
it's up to our individual conscience and
it's very important that every
individual business person refuses to
play along and rejects these kinds of
deals you have to say no everyday
temptation is always there it's crucial
that you have the willpower to resist
they were meant for vulgarities against
complicated at the moment when money
becomes a fetish and a substitute for
love that's when our human nature and
money become linked in a very unhealthy
way and we're likely to do very stupid
things one evening I was with some
co-workers at a bar we'd been drinking
and one of them who was easily earning 5
million dollars a year turned to me and
asked Reiner what do I have to do to
become really rich
that's when greed becomes disgusting
really disgusting
our hunger for more is enormous it
drives the economy and creates demand
for all kinds of products we just have
to learn to keep it under control
you